radical Islam fears bollywood bollywood
works from the inside when you have a
song and music and cultural products
going into a country they are not just
consumed at the level of entertainment
there is some deeper resonance that they
have which is why people want them and
so for a very long time you know here in
America the hope was if we can't change
the Middle East by pointing guns at it
well then you know we if Hollywood is
going to do it but the problem is
Hollywood is very very different
it's very alien and their concerns are
completely different but the one force
that actually speaks to their concerns
is Bollywood and India's film industry
the number of people who watch Bollywood
is actually larger than the number of
people who watch Hollywood I think the
figures are Hollywood its 2.6 billion
and Bollywood is 3 billion 3 billion is
literally half of the plans many of
these people live in Middle East
countries on Arab countries in Muslim
countries young people in the Middle
East are just lapping up Hollywood the
song the dance the pomp the show the hot
babes I mean they just love this stuff
bollywood appeals to the Muslim world is
that it comes from the same cultural
clock it reflects the kind of issues
that Muslims are dealing with for the
same kind of clash between tradition and
modernity that Pali word in India are
struggling with simple things like a
romantic love and who should decide who
one should marry is it the parents or is
it the boy and the girl themselves in
the West in Hollywood movies that's not
even an issue but it's a huge issue in
that part of the world and all of
Bollywood movies deal with that one
central question that young people are
preoccupied with who should decide and
this kind of this existential struggle
is the struggle of youth everywhere in
the East
to give you an example the two
blockbuster songs in recent months one
featured dancer called Sheila another
featured dancer called Mooney
but the birthday songs came out at the
same time and India and Pakistan and the
rest of the Muslim world
there was like us literally a cultural
civil war as to which of the dancers was
better when he was better or Sheila was
better who had the you know hotter moves
who was prettier who was sexier the
interesting thing in this great rivalry
between Sheila and Mooney is that Sheila
is actually in real life a Muslim woman
and the interesting thing about the
moody song was that the male lead of
that song Salman Khan the time plays the
policeman is a Muslim as well
and both songs have been choreographed
by a Muslim woman her name is Farah
Khan's
so when you have Muslims succeeding in
Bollywood as Muslims it you know makes
them feel that well you know we don't
have to give up a religion in order to
you know be modern that subtle
redefining of posture is very very
subversive
of Islamic demands and Islamic extremism
basically if you can have a good time in
this world and you can have you know
Sheline mooney in this world and still
be you know religious then why do you
need need to strap you know suicide
bombs to your chest and